sono a morgan sono qui per parlare del
futuro del calcio
beh innanzitutto permettetemi di fare
una piccola introduzione al calcio che
per molti è lo sport più bello ma questo
è chiaramente un fatto soggettivo invece
ad essere oggettivo è la sua unica
universalità perché il calcio si può
giocare sempre ed ovunque e da chiunque
basta avere un pallone ma spesso anche
qualcosa di sferico che abbia la
capacità di rotolare per far scoccare la
scintilla e iniziare a divertirsi
allora il futuro del calcio dirvelo
praticamente complicato ancor più se a
disposizione si hanno soltanto 18 minuti
ma è il mio sforzo attraverso le slits
sarà quello di proporvi una mia
immaginazione
rispetto a questo fantastico movimento
ho raccolto ho raccolto tanti dati in
questo tempo di preparazione che ha
avuto i dati soprattutto del sistema
italiano che un sistema importante un
sistema di riferimento e gli spunti che
io poi analizzerò potranno essere anche
sviluppati a livello globale
adesso vi starete chiedendo la piramide
cosa c'entra
siamo venuti qui per innovazione e 10
ritroviamo a parlare di antichi egizi no
c'entra eccome perché il riferimento è
alla struttura la struttura della
piramide è azzeccatissima se la vogliamo
paragonare a quella del calcio perché ha
una base imponente che che ne determina
la maestosità e la grandezza e così a e
per il calcio ma voi avrete fatto
sicuramente più attenzione a puntare lo
sguardo in alto al vertice questo è un
errore che spesso fanno anche i nostri
dirigenti o chi pensa al calcio e chi lo
vede quindi a me piacerebbe proprio
partire per raccontarvi come immagine il
calcio dalla base dai settori giovanili
per esempio o immagino onorabilità e
professionalità a cosa mi riferisco mi
riferisco ha fatto che nei settori
giovanili
i dirigenti i proprietari i tesserati
comunque le persone che sono a contatto
con i piccoli calciatori e calciatrici
siano delle persone qualificate abbiano
delle competenze specifiche abbiano non
solo dei valori tecnico e tattici da
insegnare ai ragazzini ma che per
esempio non siano stati condannati o non
abbiano dei procedimenti penali in corso
per fatti gravi delle certificazioni
anti pedofilia
quindi in questo senso i genitori quando
portano i bambini in queste strutture
devono avere sì la speranza che un
giorno il proprio figliolo diventi un
talento affermato ma devono avere
assolutamente la certezza che prima di
coltivare il talento vengano cresciuti
come persona
calcio dilettantistico questo questo è
evidente che rappresenta la grande parte
della struttura del movimento nel calcio
dilettantistico ci sono dei problemi
perché a un certo punto intorno ai 16
per la fascia dei tagli arriva fino a 20
anni si disperdono tesserati e
praticanti in questo avviene soprattutto
per due motivi il primo è perché a un
certo punto si dà una sensazione di
inadeguatezza rispetto a chi pratica il
calcio e questo non è auspicabile debba
continuare perché il calcio non lo
devono giocare soltanto quelli che sono
bravi e capaci ma devono giocare anche
quelli che sono meno bravi anche quelli
che sono più scarsi perché il calcio
comunque una forma di divertimento ed è
per quello che il valore sociale e
l'aspetto ludico devono essere portati
avanti
poi c'è un altro fattore che determina
la dispersione l'emorragia di tesserati
intorno a questa fascia d'età ed è
qualcosa di più tecnico si chiama
vincolo qualcuno di voi forse ne avrà
sentito parlare sarà brevissimo
in pratica a 14 anni quando ci si
tessera per una società dilettantistica
in italia si firma un tesserino che ti
vincola fine 25 anni a quel punto tu ti
sei messo delle manette e ha buttato le
chiavi
se è vincolato fino a 25 anni non potrai
più decidere dove per chi giocare nel
momento in cui eserciterai questa
facoltà se sei fortunato i titoli di
fronte a dirigenti e sensibili che
capiscono e ti permettono di esercitare
della facoltà peggio ancora è successo
frequentemente e continua a succedere ed
è testimoniato nei fatti ti ritrovi di
fronte a dirigenti e spietati che
cercano anche di astor estorcere delle
quantità di denaro e questa forma di
schiavitù moderna applicata al calcio
deve assolutamente cessare quindi
allargare la base cosa vuol dire
innanzitutto proteggerla
dopodiché attingere a quel territorio
semine sam inesplorato e fertilissimo
che il mondo del calcio femminile spesso
si usa la frase il futuro è donna
bene il calcio vi assicuro e ci tengo
tantissimo sottolineare questo che il
futuro sarà veramente donna
un numero su tutti la federazione
italiana gioco calcio ha più di un
milione di tesserati soltanto 20 21 mila
sono calciatrici allora che cosa bisogna
fare consideriamo che a livello italiano
ma anche a livello globale i dati sono
che i praticanti dello sport si in
percentuale si eguagliano tra uomini e
donne allora perché questa forbice così
grande bisogna dare l'opportunità a
tutte quelle donne e sono tante che
magari non come gli uomini ma che hanno
la passione verso il calcio non soltanto
di vederlo in televisione di ammirarlo
ma anche di poterlo praticare in maniera
dignitosa in maniera divertita
quindi ho pensato a un abbinamento con
il calcio maschile le grandi società
devono costruire ed investire su settori
giovanili preparati importanti per
arrivare anche ad avere una squadra
una prima squadra che possa fidelizzare
il rapporto con le proprie tifose
bisognerebbe rafforzare il rapporto tra
le scuole società si nelle scuole
italiane e dare l'opportunità le ragazze
che lo vogliono di poter giocare a
calcio quindi in questo senso arrivare
con un percorso progressivo anche anche
al professionismo chiaramente di elette
arbitri
cominciamo insomma a lasciare un
pochettino alla base per salire e di
arrivare anche ai livelli più alti a
quelli professionistici io parlo di
arbitri di allenatori di calciatori
insomma di tutti quelli che fanno fanno
lo spettacolo inizio dagli arbitri
e qui perché inserisco anche un discorso
di tecnologia
gli arbitri sono fondamentali va
conservata alla loro indipendenza devono
essere solo ed esclusivamente finanziati
dalle singole federazioni nessun tipo di
sponsor sponsorizzazione deve essere
ammesso si innescherebbero dei
meccanismi di conflitto di interesse
dopodiché c'è un fatto che è che
molto molto frequente sui campi di
periferia ci sono le aggressioni ai
giovani arbitri e non solo da parte dei
calciatori ma anche di tifosi dirigenti
e addirittura di genitori che portano i
bambini quando si tratta di settore di
partite di settore giovanile allora per
eliminare questo questo fenomeno o
comunque ridurlo al minimo
ci sono due linee la prima è quella che
tra l'altro la nostra federazione ha
intrapreso un inasprimento delle pene
rispetto delle pene sportive rispetto a
chi compie questo tipo di atti dopodichè
bisognerebbe dare il buon esempio
allora il buon esempio come si potrebbe
fare si potrebbe andare a livelli
altissimi e dare la possibilità agli
arbitri di introdurre quel sistema
tecnologico che la moviola in campo
della quale io sono assolutamente
convinto assertore è una cosa
chiaramente con le dovute specifiche ma
qui il tempo è poco e dobbiamo dobbiamo
andare avanti ma un altro sistema
tecnologico molto più semplice ma
efficacissimo potrebbe essere quello di
dare l'opportuna all'arbitro di usare
microfono a campo aperto e telecamera ci
si renderebbe conto di cosa gli arbitri
vedo di cosa si dicono per arrivare a
una decisione ea quel punto sarebbe
veramente nostra consapevolezza capire
che è difficile fare gli arbitri ancor
più microfono a campo aperto
potrebbe essere un perfetto deterrente
per tutti quegli atteggiamenti che i
giocatori spesso e volentieri vediamo in
televisione no di intimidazione di
linguaggio scurrile di di offesa questo
sarebbe un grande deterrente
riporterebbe tutto nella logica della
sportività e della serenità quindi la
tecnologia applicata al calcio in questo
senso potrebbe veramente funzionare gli
allenatori
permettetemi di fare anche un
complimento a quelli italiani che sono
tra i più bravi e che quindi quando
vanno in giro del mondo si si tolgono
anche delle belle soddisfazioni agli
allenatori in senso generale da parte
dei dirigenti e da parte dei tifosi
andrebbe data l'opportunità di lavorare
con serenità con un progetto perché in
quel momento loro riuscirebbero a
sviluppare
le proprie qualità sul miglioramento
della qualità del gioco
a beneficiarne sarebbe soprattutto lo
spettacolo quindi meno pressione e più
qualità nel tipo di lavoro
in questo senso l'anno scorso e faccio
riferimento sempre a questo episodio mi
trovavo a guardare quasi
consecutivamente due partite una del
campionato italiano empoli chievo e
un'altra della premier league e lester
stoke city beh vi assicuro perchè li
conosco tanti di quei giocatori che il
livello tecnico e tattico non era tanto
diverso quanto invece diversa era era il
contesto nel quale queste due partite si
sono si sono sviluppate si fa sempre
riferimento ultimamente alla premier
league che ha raggiunto dei valori
economici e di seguito incredibili
allora lo dico da italiano che vuole da
calciatore italiano che vive in questo
sistema che lo conosce e che vorrebbero
approvarsi anche della leadership che
avevamo qualche tempo fa che bisogna
lavorare in questa direzione quindi
costruire stadi nuovi riempirli campi di
gioco regolare in modo tale che il gioco
possa essere più veloce e più divertente
è più fluido e poi noi abbiamo una
grandissima potenzialità in generale
tutte le nazioni dovrebbero andare in
questa direzione ma c'è anche e
soprattutto per noi la possibilità di
applicare al calcio una sorta di turismo
sportivo che oltre alla partita
permetterebbe di calamitare le
attenzioni di tanti appassionati e
quindi farli vedere una partita e poi
farli vedere tutte le nostre
meravigliose città delle squadre che
partecipano ai campionati di serie a e
serie b e così via
calciatori qui chiaramente è più attuale
per me il discorso anche più facile
parlarne c'è un primo tipo di
discriminazione io ho scritto libera
circolazione che andrebbe eliminato in
questo caso si fa discriminazione tra
giocatori comunitari e giocatori
extracomunitari questo andrebbe
assolutamente eliminato i giocatori si
differenziano soltanto per si
differenziano soltanto per un non
abbiamo tempo alla fine vi lascerò
qualcosa per i miei applausi
comunque diciamo che i calciatori si
differenziano soprattutto per un motivo
che possono decidere una sola volta per
quale nazionale giocare quindi dovranno
dovranno farlo per il resto della loro
carriera
dopo di che ultimamente sono state
introdotte delle limitazioni alle rose e
qui il discorso è anche un po tecnico
però in linea brevissima le rose non
devono essere limitate perché le singole
società hanno esigenze diverse
ci sono squadre che si affrontano anche
del campione di serie a però squadre che
giocano 50 partite altre che ne giocano
solo 38 quindi necessariamente non si
possono avere lo stesso numero di
giocatori
se invece si vuole valorizzare il
prodotto interno quelli di quello dei
vivai e dei calciatori italiani o dei
calciatori dei singoli campionati a quel
punto si potrebbe inserire un numero
minimo di calciatore italiano e degli
altri paesi all'interno delle proprie
rose e poi alla fine le seconde squadre
anche qui siamo sui tecnicismi ma ci
tengo a raccontarveli e seconde squadre
soprattutto per le sue più importanti
servirebbero a valorizzare quei
giocatori in particolar modo giovani che
non riescono a trovare lo spazio nelle
prime squadre domenicalmente e quindi
avere l'opportunità di fare campionati
minori tipo la serie b la sia decisa e
sono bravi ad arrivarci e quindi
esprimere migliorare il proprio talento
arriviamo a una considerazione che che
sta riguardando molto chi segue il
calcio
in questo periodo mi riferisco al format
dei campionati io sono partito da un
modello italiano dove vede una serie a a
16 squadre con due retrocessioni serie b
a 18 e via discorrendo
avete qui dietro tutta da che cosa
innanzitutto c'è il fatto di ridurre il
numero delle squadre perché perché
bisogna ridurre il numero delle partite
i calciatori hanno l'esigenza di giocare
meno perché perché giocando meno si può
ricoverare di più ci si può allenare
meglio ci si infortuna reb e meno e
soprattutto si migliorerebbe la qualità
dello spettacolo
questo è fondamentale per continuare o
meglio migliorare l'offerta che si vuole
proporre ai tifosi e agli appassionati
di calcio
qui ho parlato anche di nazionale di
state stage estivi a cosa mi riferisco
adesso c'è un calendario della fifa
veramente cervellotico e schizofrenico e
purtroppo ci sarà fino al 2022 quindi ai
mondiali del qatar con questo tipo di
calendario
gli impegni e dei club e quelli delle
nazionali vengono mischiati allora che
cosa bisognerebbe fare sarebbe
auspicabile avvenisse che le parti della
nazionale venissero concentrate per un
periodo di 7 settimane circa tra la
la metà di maggio alla fine di giugno a
quel punto sicuramente non ci sarebbero
più discorsi di interesse conflittuale
tra i club e le federazioni i calciatori
potrebbero dedicarsi per un periodo al
club è successo e successivamente le
nazionali senza mischiare anche il
pubblico avrebbe l'opportunità di non di
non essere in continua schizofrenia
rispetto a degli eventi che cambiano da
un momento all'altro questo sarebbe
veramente una cosa fondamentale anche
per evitare problemi logistici di
infortuni e via discorrendo
in conclusione arriviamo a quella che
secondo me a breve tempo succederà ne
stanno parlando tanto però bisognerebbe
trovare la forma giusta
la formula giusta ecco questa è la
formula giusta che ho pensato in questo
momento a livello internazionale la
competizione più importante al mondo per
club e la champions league
oltre alla champions league in europa si
organizza un altra competizione che
quella dell'europa league
queste due competizioni sono sì
prestigiose ma per valori economici e di
seguito si differenziano tantissimo
allora l'idea quale è unificare in un
con un'unica competizione internazionale
e fare una superlega da 64 squadre 64
squadre 16 gironi da quattro squadre le
prime due si qualificano sedicesimi e
così via fino alla finale perché questo
perché si darebbe l'opportunità alle 54
federazioni iscritte nella uefa di cui
18 e non hanno mai avuto una
rappresentanza nella fase finale nella
fase finale della champions league e si
darebbe l'opportunità di avere un posto
garantito senza preliminari senza
qualificazione
dopodichè alle 18 che non ancora hanno
avuto l'opportunità si potrebbe si
potrebbe organizzare un torneo estivo
che che darebbe un posto a quel punto
attraverso quello che un sistema americo
meritocratico che si chiama il ranking
il ranking uefa per club si sarebbe una
di script distribuzione dei posti senza
passare attraverso i preliminari come
come
e descritto quindi e troverebbe fuori
sicuramente dal punto di vista economico
una cosa molto interessante garantirebbe
gli investimenti a tante società che che
che si espongono e comicamente per
raccogliere sia risultati in termini
sportivi che in termini che in termini
economici quindi per concludere posso
dire con assoluta convinzione che il
calcio ci sarà sempre e al di là di
probabili cambiamenti
speriamo migliorativi continuerà ad
essere fantastico e unico aggregatore
sociale
i valori che non possono essere
disconosciuti rispetto al calcio sono
valori importanti
parliamo di quello sportivo emozionale
del valore economico del valore ripeto
sociale di aggregazione doping teppismo
da stadio calcioscommesse fallimenti
societari
io non ho parlato appositamente di
questi fenomeni perché il calcio non
c'entra anzi è vittima di tutto ciò e
per questo bisogna chiamare in causa la
responsabilità penale e personale di chi
si macchia di questi reati
ho proposto idee innovazioni alcune già
sentite altre assolutamente innovative
ma l'aspetto più importante è che ci sia
presto un cambio di persone in mentalità
nella governance del calcio a tutti i
livelli
gli scandali sono molto attuali ma non
c'entrano
soltanto gli scandali basta con
personaggi legati agli interessi
personali lobbistici conservatori e
spesso anche i criminali
c'è l'esigenza di migliorare l'intero
movimento calcistico attraverso capacità
serietà lungimiranza interesse
collettivo
all'inizio ascoltato la mia
presentazione molto molto precisa però
mi piace mi piacerebbe sintetizzarla con
le parole di un famosissimo cantatore
italiano lorenzo jovanotti meraviglioso
poeta dei tempi moderni la sintetizzerei
con sono un ragazzo fortunato si sono un
ragazzo fortunato perché mi hanno
regalato un sogno
questo sogno per me si chiama calcio
custodirlo e fare in modo che tutti
possano sognare e l'obiettivo
io vi ringrazio per l'attenzione
nei 18 minuti ci siamo rientrati
permettetemi sarà anche anacronistico di
fare questa dedica a tutte quelle
persone che ieri hanno sofferto tanto
e che hanno toccato la sensibilità di
tutti quanti noi ma anche 48 ore fa il
mondo del calcio ha perso due portieri
tra l'altro giovanissimi marton fulop
ungherese e tommaso trani di 21 anni
italiano allora o il bio ricerca